hot breath so jason fox asks when first
starting comedy
how did you handle when sets would bomb
and what kept you going
ugh it
i feel like those bombs probably felt
worse just so bad i mean bombs suck
[Music]
like after a while i went through a
period of like honestly just not bombing
because i wouldn't let myself
and that's bad too because
you're just sort of like i don't know i
think you gotta
you gotta push through the ball you
gotta bomb to get great i guess
i i mean but i really did go through a
period of avoiding bombs like
i said i think that sounds like well how
did you do that and it's like well you
just do what you know works and you
don't really push too hard or test
anything
and you're kind of scared you're just
performing scared
so wait what was the question
it was when first started comedy how did
you handle
sets that would bomb and what kept you
going
god i mean how did i handle them
embarrassment like just you know you
feel shame you want to crawl in a hole
um how did i handle them i still handle
probably everything the same way just
like with a bowl of ice cream right
before bed
what kept me going i don't know
a sick a sickness
a um you know
i used to say like you know
i guess in stand-up it's a mix of things
there's all different kinds of us but
pretty much all the same where
you kind of have to be a little dumb
like okay you have to be very smart to
be a good comic i think
until
you can tell us intellectual and in
other comics
um i guess this i'm all over the place
right now
i think to be funny you have to be smart
like that's
that's a fact it doesn't mean school
smart i'm just saying like you have to
have
a sharpness to you um
i think so that sounds like i'm saying
i'm i think i'm some sort of genius but
you're doing it you're doing great here
we're all having fun
you're you're a very successful comedian
that
deserves to be where you are we're
grateful you're even willing to take
time out of your important day
to be here with us all of your words
hold
extreme value and relevance
okay um i forget where i was going with
this
i think the question is still about
bombing oh oh oh
okay so you kind of have to be dumb
though
to be to think i have something to say
you know like it's a mix because like i
didn't start out thinking like i'm gonna
change the world and
everybody must listen to me and i blah
blah blah you have to be a little dumb
to be like i'm gonna move to l.a
how but cause like part of me was like
it's not that i thought i was like i'm
gonna move there and make it and be
huge i just was like i can do this
and like i guess the thing that kept me
going
was the fact that i wanted to try and
see if i could
i mean and
the end goals goal setting i suppose
that's what kept me going
i always would write down my goals and
they've changed over time but they used
to be things like
perform at comedians you should know
perform at the lakeshore theater
a late night set you know um i
would get specific but um
yeah they're just so so goal setting and
then you have
a bit of blindness to keep going because
if you start doing the math on it
you're not gonna make it baby
and obviously the joy and the passion of
making people laugh
and your goals can change over over time
they will
and what you're going for i think it's
some sometimes
sorry there's this girl who lives above
me is like i can hear her
dropping something weights or
the momentum of this interview
is this interview bombing
no i just want to be like bam bam bam
bam bam bam bam bam bamb
oh people are commenting still love her
energy someone i'd want to hang out with
they're
they're encouraging you in the comments
right now beth
that's fun we're all in this together
yes we are i
i think too obviously this is like a
weird time where
where like i was saying before at the
beginning i don't know if we were
recording yet but it's like
do i need to put content out right now
like is it
am i really like making people's days
better if i push to put
put something out or is it best to just
like kind of chill and this is like the
the world is saying like take a break
here for a second
um but
yeah bombing is it i think
i think your answer yeah you definitely
answered that oh yeah just the idea
you're just like why what do i have to
say so i think that changes over time
because i've said a lot
you know i have a good amount of things
that i've put out and this next hour
for me was very very much a passion
project so you know the morning after
i filmed my special was very cathartic
you know it's like
i put so much time and energy and years
into it
um because it should be something you're
proud of and
special and so i think the next steps of
building
now i'm back at square one where i was
three years ago
and you're like i'm almost in the place
where i'm just like
should you come and see me live i mean
like i shouldn't say that public
um but because it's like it's not gonna
be good yet
so like to me when you see a comic is
is um i don't know the word i'm looking
for
it really hinges on where they are and
in that portion of their material
because like technically
if this special comes out and you come
see me in september if we're allowed to
leave our houses
it's like is it going to be me just
trying new material that i've
written during this quarantine i don't
want to come out and just do quarantine
jokes for people i don't think that's
that's not what i want to be putting out
so it's like what do i have to say now
life has changed it will be different
yeah it's like it's just it's odd where
you catch a comic
in their generation of material
so even like i said come like seeing me
just before i filmed the special in
seattle what a great show i had a blast
they were like those things were those
jokes were right where i wanted them
and now do i go and be the comic that
performs the special you just watched
no i think you have to find a mix
but that but there's no boss of me
except for me and you also don't want to
be the comic that comes on like what do
you guys want to hear
like you have to go out and be sure so
it's like
i've talked to nate bargetti about it
after filming a special putting out and
his kind of tactic is sort of just like
hey i'm going to give you as much new as
i can
and we'll have fun and then i'll tell
some of the
old stuff and they'll like no way so
i think my sister will always tell me
like beth
you know when you go see your favorite
musician you want to hear
crazy in love you know